[موسيقى]
للشمس مسارات متغيره ولهذا مكان وزمان
شروق وغروب الشمس يختلف بشكل يومي ومسارها
يختلف بشكل فصلي فمسارها في الشتاء اقصر
من الصيف ولهذا اطول نهر السنه في عز
القيظ واطول ليالي السنه في عز الشتاء
والشمس الان وصلت منتصف المسافه بين مدار
الجدي وخط الاستواء وبعد شهر تقريبا 16
مارس ستصل الى خط الاستواء وحين ذاك
يتساوى فيه طول الليل مع النهار دعد دموعي
تسيل سيلا بدارا وضلوعي يصلين بالودي نارا
قد اعاد الاسى نهاريه ليلا منذ اعاد
المشيب ليلي
نهارا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وهنا الاولين الله يرحمهم ويعرفون تساوي
الليل مع النهار من مكان شروه وغروب الشمس
فاذا اشرقت الشمس من المشرق تماما وغربت
من المغرب تماما قالوا هذا اماره وعلامه
على تساوي الليل مع النهار ويعرفونها ايضا
بالسلوك الحشري فاذا طلع ابا دار بين
قوسين الجعلان قالوا اذا طلع ابا ذر تساوي
الليل مع النهار
[موسيقى]